hallo Christoph hallo Thomas
zunächst einmal herzlichen Dank für
diese mal ganz andere Möglichkeit
Antworten auf die Fragen die uns
beschäftigen zu bekommen
mein Name ist Nicole bzw Niko Baum in
der Community und das hier ist mein Sohn
Erik
der im August in Köln dabei war und im
September in Würzburg wo er auch nach
dem Soundcheck Thomas mal hallo sagen
konnte
ich habe hier ein paar Fragen von
verschiedenen Usern aus der Community
zusammengefasst die Erik und ich nun
stellvertretenden
die erste Frage ist von Selmas 69 in wie
weit warst du auch in die
kompositorische Seite der Song
Entstehung und das musikalischen
Arrangements involviert hattest du zum
Beispiel Einfluss auf den Einsatz von
background gehören und ähnlichen wie zum
Beispiel bei Schnee von gestern oder
Stückchen Ewigkeit und wenn ja welche
Wirkung soll damit erzählt werden wenn
nicht werden diese weiterhin ein
Stilmittel in deiner Musik sein das so
wie wie das alles aus produziert wurde
ist nach meinem wünschen entstanden und
das wollte ich halt so und
er hat mir natürlich auch ein paar
natürlich paar Leute auch mit ins Boot
geholt weil ich nicht auch ganz viel
Zeit hatte letztendlich und ich wollte
gleich recht fixhalt mit dem neuen Album
ja einfach zeigen so dass man dass man
auch an an selbst an einem Album viel
viel arbeitet und anlegt und das war mir
halt ganz wichtig und habe mir natürlich
die passenden Leute auch dazu gefunden
dazu gesucht
raus hat gleich zwei Fragen
überhaupt
mit wie kommt es dass die hohen Töne am
Anfang von Schnee von gestern z.B ganz
anders bzw besser klingen als noch bei
love you oder klingen sie gar nicht
anders und ich meine das nur
nehmen kann gesagt Unterricht mehr aber
wir sind halt für mich speziell in den
ähm und ähm mach mal eine gesangsübung
die ich halt noch so
ja aus alten Zeiten noch mit äh
mitgenommen hat und jeder Song
entwickelt sich auch immer speziell und
ich versuche dann immer sehr viel mit
meiner Stimme zu variieren und kleine
hier öfter man oder je mehr man singt
desto mehr Breite bekommt man einfach
auch und ja man sagt ja nicht umsonst
Übung macht den Meister
versuchst du dich davor zu schützen dass
deine Stimme auf der Tour zum Beispiel
durch Erkältungen zu sehr beansprucht
werden könnte also in erster Linie
braucht man einfach bei der ganzen
Touren und wenn man so zwei Stunden
Programm durchzieht natürlich sehr viel
Schlaf im Nachhinein und ich trinke
immer sehr viel Tee viel Flüssigkeit auf
jeden Fall dann sind die Stimmbänder
auch gut befeuchtet und auch elastisch
und nach dem Konzert sollte man auf
jeden Fall auch mal die Klappe halten
also einfach mal nichts erzählen und
sich viel ausruhen das ist ganz wichtig
Schatz oder Buttons oder sonstiges geben
bisher ist da ja nichts erhältlich ja
also der Vertrag mit Deutschrock läuft
jetzt am Ende des Jahres aus und es wird
auch wir haben jetzt auch noch zwei neue
T-Shirts mit angebracht also Tour Shirts
die wir gemacht haben und dann ist es ja
gibt es ein ganz neues ähm reparatoren
und ja
da kommt noch auf jeden Fall noch ein
paar Sachen auf uns zu